welcome to this video player sham
acetate from the US so a Sicilian hmm
yeah should I play main line or some
something else check this is some
getting popular recently the check now
this is quite a good line of thing for
black also playable against um the the
purusa limo with the 96 and move to he
somehow has not done preventing me from
playing deform but I'd like to invest
the move to prove to a void Bishop g4 so
if I go t for now he probably will take
and played d5 what but it's not a bad
position for white
for some reason I now have this green
squares I don't know why I must have
changed some setting here I think it was
read before and I'm not quite sure why
he's investing time here okay it didn't
take which seems strange hmm why would
you not take okay yellow d5 was also
good but let's let's do this here it's
not bad at all getting space in the
center Bishop f4 this looks like a good
setup yup he will go to e6 and I dropped
back to g2 g3 should I play be five I
mean not be 5 a-4 to hit to play against
be five but don't don't think it's a
it's necessary b5 is also just weakening
for him doesn't really bring any big
break cam dividends don't shoot to h6
okay
I'm not sure what what Bishop h6 is all
about okay just to prepare booty one
first if he decides to go back to have
six I have Knight f6 quite a funny funny
idea based on this discovery
yeah this is certainly a comfortable
position but how to make any substantial
progress it's not so easy I go here try
to a tech c5 hey maybe I can try that
too we just ignores it yeah okay maybe
this sir is so it's not so good as a
thought but slowly played this very very
quickly I me here using this discovery
and maybe I'm able to to take Jack kick
him and play 96 so that I don't yeah I'm
96 it's not on or is it mmm yeah I can
also just just drop back
yeah I don't really understand why he
sacrificed on 1c5 but so it's just just
a pawn down for for nothing
hmm young
just just take it and keep it simple I
wonder if I can do something with the
the loose position of them the bishop
here
yeah well come on not i'm down on the
clock but how come he's not he's just
playing instant moves and hopes for the
best not really thinking about what he's
doing I mean if I've just gives away
another pawn okay how to proceed now
yeah F to sell as hanging I can I can
take p.m. playing give this check so one
of the one of the Moose rip t5 rock f2m
this is not really look everyone now so
there's a threat okay that's am take
here first
I can check here or i can just cover it
i mean this is this is the easiest
96 now
yeah not quite sure may know what what
are my moves besides 96 the 94 just grab
more material
now could create black resins guy just
gave away a couple of points for for no
good reason and yeah this is this plate
after three seconds of just tear away
the Dwight if white is just winning here
check I will need to spend far too much
time yeah maybe around here I mean it
looks very shaky this this oops
it's also strange move but okay this
this is looking very shaky this is
bishop like this kind of ideas today
they are simply in the position but then
okay can he can cover this kind of stuff
it's not it's not quite working for
white but ok I think this was so simple
and good with this idea and this yeah
well I don't understand it and just take
take the pawn and he resigns basically
all right thanks for watching